i'm going to start out by thanking you
from the bottom of my heart because
uh when we started imagining these last
couple of shows
you you put it off we knew that we were
going to wind it down
and then they started to ask me who i'd
like to be there and
i i said just very few names and one
that was really important to me was bill
you because you're one of uh
thanks uh thank you i've known you for a
bunch of year
uh so for so many years and you're just
uh make me laugh there's people that
make me laugh and then you just make me
laugh to the point where i'm
uh like visibly uh unsettled
and uh that's insane well that's crazy
for me to hear
you know my very first time ever on a
talk show was
your show uh and i
okay so in 1993 let's all go back there
do we have to yeah let's go back to 1993
and i we had uh off-campus uh lunch at
my high school and i would go to my
friend my friend jake thomas's house
and we would eat macaroni and cheese and
he would tape this new show
late night conan o'brien and i would
watch it with him
and just we would just laugh
until we were sick and it was the first
thing in comedy that was mine it was the
first thing that like
my parents didn't understand
[Laughter]
mine still don't understand yeah yeah
yeah but my parents didn't get it
i was so then when i was like you know i
got to start out live and they said hey
you know
they're they're they you know you're
gonna go do conan i was
freaking out and it was my first i
didn't sleep the night before i was like
oh my gosh this is crazy
and i went out and we did it and um you
were horrible to me
you were just a a that's what i do with
the young guys
you know i just try and set the bar you
know i just let them know
contacts they went to a commercial and
you were like oh
big man oh
barrel chested ball apparently i was
looking at you
for help and they're like
they're interested man yeah yeah and
then i fought you in the parking lot
you did yeah you're right yeah i was
walking out to my car and you went not
so fast
i'm gonna fight you and i was like
you're my hero
get up get up featured player
[Applause]
i did this with everyone you gotta
understand this is my initiation